chypre est un choix qu'on fait c'est
l'action
tour à tour
mais ma libération populaire je pense
que gilles hudon journal j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment intéressant mais l'atelier
djamel pays de montfort de ville mont
royal mais j'ai terminé mon dieu vous
autres je pense pas jenna dow jones
lâche pas aveugle et je vois bien que
pour une poignée de riches ça prend 10
millions pour d'exploiter puis des mini
fusées rencontre une autre dépression
que ceux qui changent progrès au québec
ça des gens comme aux autres ça se passe
alors tu m'expliques de ce que bush je
compulse ça fait longtemps que nous on
est partis n'ont pas pu reculer robin on
est des militants
navarro n'est pas des meurtriers leurs
besoins d'amendements poser des gestes
concrets pour décoloniser québec la
grenade semprun ce que c'était un geste
concret
les gens commencent à comprendre quelle
femme n'a rien la politique cette
attention ouzou
je veux savoir ce que les mecs top 10
mon époque ça ne tient qu'à aux autres
il faut toujours rester bourgeois des
montréalais
vous avez jusqu'au bout comment
pardonner